during Makai was a big hitter the
bookies favorite to be Scotland's next
verse Minister no more
not after Holyrood walked to lurid
newspaper tales about the politician and
his private messages to a 16 year old
boy
Darren Makai with Scotland's finance
secretary and this of all days was the
day he was due to set out the Scottish
budget to Parliament he stepped down
overnight
when the story broke about the teenager
he contacted out of the blue and sent
270 messages over several months they
included this on the 27th of December
last year and our chats are between us
he said yes said the teenager cool to be
honest I think you're really cute is
that okay said the politician just as
long as you know he said but you can
delete that message whoa one last
September read what age are you by the
way the youngster said sixteen all right
said derec Makai overnight Nicola
Sturgeon had accepted her ministers
resignation from government having read
the newspaper article she suspended him
from her SNP party Derek Mackay his
conduct fell far short of what is
expected of a minister indeed he offered
his resignation to me and I accepted it
was not an option for him to remain in
government he has also been suspended
from both the SNP and the parliamentary
group pending further investigation
there was no answer from Darren McKay's
constituency office in Renfrew he'd
earlier issued a statement which read I
take full responsibility for my actions
I've behaved foolishly and I am truly
sorry I apologise unreservedly to the
individual involved and his family
suspended he may be but he remains for
now at least MSP for rent for north and
west I can't do that and then expect to
still be and government and I wouldn't
want him representing me in my family
and nesting age it doesn't matter what
you do you know if you sort of cross the
line yeah you know you die in your sword
so I think the police have commented on
this matter but only to say they've
received
complained of any criminality they're
assessing available information from
media reporting and have encouraged
anyone with information to come forward
this is a budget that offers vision and
leadership back at the Scottish
Parliament the budget went ahead as
scripted if not as planned
with a fellow minister acting as
stand-in a big date in Scotland's
political calendar - it's big casualty
James Matthews Sky News Renfrew